foreign
now
so
ladies and gentlemen the honorable
whitley general hopkinson and major
general walker will be out in just a
moment
they'll make brief opening statements
and we'll have time for questions uh we
are also sending out a press release
you'll see that in your inboxes later
this afternoon
we do have a list of reporters both here
in the room and on the phone and so i'll
call
on folks by name who've indicated they
have questions and we'll begin
momentarily thank you
we have 75
[Music]
[Music]
you ready to go uh hello do i need to do
anything for this
[Music]
good afternoon i want to give you a
quick update on the status of our
national guard airmen and soldiers
performing duties capital uh at the
capitol
uh i'm john whitley the acting secretary
of the army i'm joined by i think
most of you probably know general dan
hopkinson chief of the national guard
and uh general major general william
walker commander of the dc national
guard
to begin i'd like to thank our national
guard soldiers and airmen for the hard
work
swift response and steadfast dedication
they've committed ensuring that our
capital remains secure
i'm incredibly proud of our
airmen and soldiers serving in support
of local and federal law enforcement
activities
this mission shows the breadth
flexibility and resolve of the national
guard
and the sacrifice and service it
provides to our nation
i'd like to thank the governors who
volunteered their guardsmen the mayor of
d.c
and our local and federal law
enforcement partners
as we continue to work to meet post
inauguration requirements
the national guard has been requested to
continue supporting federal law
enforcement agencies
with about seven thousand personnel for
the coming weeks
that uh presence will likely draw down
to about five thousand by mid-march
i'm going to go through the specifics of
that we've received four requests
for follow-on assistance from federal
and municipal partners
the requests have come from the u.s park
police u.s secret service
the capitol police and the metropolitan
police department of washington d.c
uh all four requests have been approved
the federal request by the secretary of
defense the municipal request by myself
the acting secretary of the army
national guard service members will
provide a variety of support
including security communications
medical evacuation
logistics and safety support to these
organizations
support to the metropolitan police
department and the u.s park police will
continue through the end of january and
the first week of february respectively
with about uh 500 uh supporting
uh the park uh 500 supporting municipal
uh
mpd the municipal police department
about 550 uh supporting
uh that's backwards i'm sorry about 500
supporting the park police no 550
supporting metropolitan police
department
approximately 600 will be supporting the
secret service
and approximately 5 000 will be
supporting the capitol police
national guard members will be postured
to meet the requirements of the
supported civil authorities
up to and including protective equipment
and arming uh
if necessary i'd now like to turn it
over to general hopkinson
uh for his opening statement
good afternoon i'm dan hilkinson i want
to thank you for the opportunity to give
you an update on what our national guard
soldiers and airmen are doing here at
home
and around the globe as i speak there
are approximately 13 000 national guard
men and women here in the district of
columbia
primarily conducting security missions
in support of our district and federal
partners
as the secretary mentioned we should all
be proud of the effort of these soldiers
and airmen
i continue to visit with them daily to
ensure they have everything they need
and let me be clear the logistics
involved in moving 25 000 people from
every state and territory
to dc in less than two weeks and
supporting them
is unprecedented it speaks volumes
about the support we receive from our
governors and adjutants general
it also speaks to the investment america
has made in the national guard's ability
to respond whenever and wherever we are
needed
i'd also like to recognize our logistics
professionals behind our troops
they're doing everything they can to
support every aspect of their missions
as requested by the federal agencies we
are supporting we're drawing down to 7
000 soldiers and airmen by the end of
this week
and that number will decrease based on
the support requirements from our
federal partners
as we right sides the national guard
here in d.c there are over 23 thousand
guard members working with community
partners
in support of the covet 19 response
they're providing vaccines testing
screening and supporting local food
banks
in addition nearly thirty thousand guard
members have received their first dose
of the coven 19 vaccine
so they can remain ready for any mission
we also continue to support overseas
combat operations
and today there are more than 72 000
guard soldiers and airmen
engaged in the homeland and overseas
the outpouring of support we have
received from our community partners has
been extraordinary
over the past week i've received
multiple phone calls from president
biden members of our congressional
delegations
and military service organizations
expressing their thanks to the
incredible
soldiers and airmen who have left their
employers and their families
to serve their nation on behalf of our
guard members i want to thank everyone
president biden members of congress the
uso
the residents here of d.c the many local
business offices who've shown their
support
the governors and adjutants general and
especially our national
families and their employers their
support
generosity and kind words are genuinely
appreciated
and for all of us it's an honor to serve
you
with that i'll turn it over to major
general walker the commanding general of
the dc national guard
good afternoon everyone i'm william
walker commanding general of district of
columbia national guard
it's a privilege to be with you all this
afternoon
on behalf of the entire district of
columbia national guard
i want to thank all the national
guardsmen 25 000
plus who came to support the district of
columbia national guard with our mission
to help the secret service with the 59th
presidential inauguration
i also want to thank their families and
their employers
for their patience and cooperation and
understanding that we needed every
single one of those guardsmen
here to support us as we supported
federal
and district of columbia law enforcement
our tasking in support of the 59th
presidential inauguration
was to help provide security protection
of life preservation of property
and to ensure public safety we had the
cooperation
and the understanding and the patience
of the community
around the capital and that i want to
thank
the residents of the capital area
for that understanding we know we
inconvenienced them
but they understood the reason why i'm
proud of the role
the district of columbia national guard
played in the role the entire national
guard
what we foundly found fondly call guard
nation
played in supporting the united states
capitol police
the metropolitan police department the
united states secret service
the park police and the
others that supported this mission
i am very proud of the discipline and
professionalism displayed by
us army soldiers guardsmen
soldiers and airmen and uh i believe we
are uniquely suited
for this mission and we are continuing
to provide the requested assistance
and will do so as long as necessary the
district of columbia national guard
stands ready
to support the the capital and so
um as the secretary and the chief of the
national guard bill said
we're here to support thank you very
much
first question to the associated press
oh thank you this is
bobby there i think you might be on mute
or the
security threat that you're seeing and
hearing and being told of that
justify keeps keeping 5000
national guard troops uh at the capitol
for some some time to come i think
that cut in and out a little bit i think
the question was about what's the
security picture what's the threats that
we're facing what do we know about those
threats
um we you know we receive briefings we
uh
we do not uh engage in that intelligence
work ourselves we
we rely on our federal partners and
particularly the fbi to provide that
information
and so what i can tell you in terms of
what they're briefing us
is our several upcoming events uh we
don't know what they are
uh over the next uh several weeks and
they're concerned that there could be
situations where there are
lawful protests first amendment
protected protests that could
either be used by by
malicious actors or other problems that
could emerge
so i'll defer to the fbi to talk about
those threats specifically but what uh
we're briefed
on a very regular basis about those and
we are uh posturing our forces
uh to be able to respond to those
threats if uh uh if they emerge
and i would just add that the number
5000 is directly
related to the uh the request for
assistance from the
u.s capitol police npr
uh this guard effort on capitol hill in
dc thousands of guard members going into
march who's in command of this is it the
dc guard
is it uh the guard bureau or the army
and also
general uh you know 12 guard soldiers
were removed
right before the inaugural i guess two
for incendiary comments
10 others also removed did that have to
do with extremism
and have you had to remove anyone else
since then for whatever reason
i'll start with a chain of command and
then i'll turn it over to general walker
to talk about
the chain of command and his uh
responsibilities and then i'll turn over
generally
so the chain of command for the forces
while they're here
in dc uh are they report to the
commander of the dc national guard
general walker reports to myself i
report to the secretary of defense
secretary of defense reports of the
president that's the chain of command
for the forces on the ground
those forces are being provided by other
states and governors
and they have important responsibilities
there but for control on the ground
for military operations uh that's the
chain of command
so to get after your question about the
12 we had 25 000
plus guardsmen here the fbi
said that 12 didn't tell us why just
said that 12 were questionable
and we're not taking any chances we're
not accepting any risk
we sent those guardsmen back to their
home state
but any others removed since the
inaugural for no sir just those 12.
okay on the phone david martin cbs
[Music]
one other uh number that was out there
last week was the
number of uh guardsmen who had tested
positive for
uh kobe um then the number was
uh roughly 150 are the
uh a coveted cases still going up
and and uh how many uh
uh troops have you had to put into uh
quarantine so thank you for the question
i'm deeply troubled by the number we're
almost at 200 right now
what happens um we follow the cdc
guidelines
the department of defense protocols we
test and screen
however we have that number
so what happens is once uh we send a
soldier
or airmen to a treatment facility for a
test they come up positive
they are quarantined and they remain
here until
um they are cleared to go back to their
state
and one thing i would add is that and
that's out of the 25 000 so it's well
less than one percent but we take every
um case seriously and
want to make sure i know will's folks
are checking on them every single day
and we did allocate the 14 days of
rom for them to stay here so that
they're fully recovered before they go
back home
yes sir here in the world members of
their unit who were in
close contact with them do they have to
uh quarantine as well
so that 200 gets multiplied by some
other number so we do contract contact
tracing
and then you know we're pretty well
separated
but yes sir so so they would be tested
to see if they
are positive and then they would be
quarantined as well
can you tell me roughly how many are in
quarantine right now
i don't have those numbers sir
an with mcclatchy for the 12 who were
sent home can you tell us will there be
any additional administrative action
taken
will they be removed from duty or i
guess have an
extensive investigation and then uh are
at least
a couple of guard members who have been
arrested who are at their
at the rally not in their official
capacity
has this prompted a deeper review by the
guard of
all of its members for extremism so i
can answer the
with respect to the 12. so the ones that
were identified
that information is provided back to
their chain of command and whether it's
a law enforcement or chain of command
issue
on whatever is appropriate will be
addressed immediately
um i'll just i'll just say uh with
respect to
uh i think your press was also getting
at the the challenge we have extremism
and ranks and i i think you know i can
certainly speak
for the army and i certainly speak for
the secretary of defense when
you know we view that as uh unacceptable
and uh uh and i would put that uh we
have a variety of challenges that we're
dealing with i think
the incoming secretary met with with all
of us this morning
and emphasized his priorities and and so
it's extremism in the ranks it's the
sexual harassment sexual assault
problems we have
um and and we have problems with suicide
and so we take all three of those uh
very seriously i think you've heard
general mcconnell the chief of staff of
the army
uh talking about people first and that
is really
the way we are structuring priorities
i'm here in an interim capacity that's
certainly my priority and i'm sure it'll
be
my successor's priority when he comes he
or she comes in
as well so um it's unacceptable
and uh and we're gonna continue to work
on it and then uh
secondly as a separate follow-up um can
you talk to us about
what additional roles the guard may be
taking on as
the biden administration expands the
covid vaccine rollout
so we're in very close contact with the
governors and the adjutants general in
each state as i mentioned we have 23 000
right now doing that
and in 31 of those states they're
actually we have guardsmen administering
vaccines to the civilian population
and so we stand ready to assist in any
way that we can
to make sure that we can we can really
help as much as possible
and that's related not only to the state
plans but also uh related to operation
warp speed
thank you all right reuters
um thanks for that um i mean you know
this better than i do but you know
extremism is usually sort of based on an
ideology that can you know take years
and sort of decades to get rid of
and i was just wondering if you had any
conversations
you know with the capital police to say
hey look guys you have a budget of you
know over 500 billion you have two
thousand officers
you don't mind taking more of a lead on
this or
you okay with the guard having this
mission in perpetuity because
you know sure in march there's an
impeachment but over the course of
year there'll be several events that
could be securely interesting so at what
point do you say
you know enough is enough you know we're
happy to help but we just can't stay
here forever
i can speak to that from a policy
perspective and you know certainly the
policy department offense we believe
that military forces should be used as a
last resort
um we believe that all law enforcement
options should be explored before
uh military forces are are called upon
and asked uh
to respond uh you know we faced an
unprecedented crisis over the last three
weeks
and our united states military
particularly the national guard
uh responded in an exemplary uh manner
and we will always do that
if there's a need uh for the security of
our nation
so we will always respond if the need is
there uh going forward from a long-term
perspective
we want to continue to emphasize to our
partners that we should be the last port
of call the last resort
uh and that every uh step should be
taken to
uh to use appropriate law enforcement
law enforcement partnerships and
bringing in law enforcement personnel
before
we're called upon uh in the short run
you you use the forces you have
so in the long term we'd like to work
with those partners uh
and try to uh uh uh
uh uh ensure that we are the last uh
uh place called the ram translator
is listening to you or do you feel that
you know given the perceived failure
that they had
uh jack a bit too much
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't catch that
i was just saying i mean do you believe
the capital police are
listening to you when you tell them that
um the national guard should be
uh we we have an outstanding
relationship
uh with all of our partners including uh
the capitol hill
uh we've worked very closely with
remember the congress members of our
oversight committees as well as the
capitol hill police
uh so uh i think we've had uh uh
very positive dialogues over time we
talk about
emplacement of forces we talk about the
employment of forces we talk about
what specific needs might be but i also
want to emphasize
they are the requester and we are the
the provider the supplier
so at the end of the day they made a
request to us and
we analyzed that request determined what
we could supply and we were able to
support
uh we believe we're going to be able to
support the entire request and so we're
supporting the request
so yes there is dialogue we believe and
our experience has been that dialogue is
productive and helpful uh but at the end
of the day
uh they are in the lead and we are in
support and uh we're very conscious of
that and
and very much try to stick to that
relationship
and in the name of tam sweater
actually i have two questions one will
those guardsmen be armed and equipped
while
in dc and the other question on social
media we have seen
dozens of images of national guard men
guardsmen
lying on background in parking lots and
then of course
it was criticized a lot what's your
reaction to this
you don't get that do you want to hit
the army now yes sir so so the guardsmen
are armed as the secretary just stated
we are in support
of a federal or district of columbia
civil authority so we were requested to
be armed
everybody is not armed but we we are
providing the level of security that was
requested by us
on behalf of the united states capitol
police regarding the photographs of
soldiers
and they've taken a break every single
guardsman
every single guardsman has a hotel
but you stand 12 hours uh on on your
feet you want to take a break
and that's what these guardsmen were
doing they were taking a as we say in
the military taking a knee
so they took a knee and sometimes they
did more than that they actually laid
down
but nobody slept there nobody spent the
night there
you know they could just add that that
was just an unfortunate incident
but once the chain of command was
notified um they established the
procedures got everybody back in and
in fact this weekend i got a chance to
tour all the uh the
facilities they've got interior warming
rooms to keep everybody warm for their
break um and the time they have between
their
eight or 12 hour shift that's out there
and i think we've we've gone well past
that
um it's one of those things we find an
issue we resolve it as quickly as we can
and and i don't see any issues right now
but thank you
you made a follow-up in the room here
it's very good
um so my question is um piggybacking off
of what he just asked
um are there being any investigations
done or are you
taking steps to make sure that guardsmen
aren't posting
their locations on social media because
this whole firestorm happened after
someone anonymously
from the guard posted photos about it so
what's going to be the repercussions if
you are able to find out who posted
those because i know when i was in the
dc national guard
you were not allowed to post your
locations on a deployment because you
put your unit
in danger and you know it makes the unit
a target
and not only that you're not supposed to
talk against your employers even if
you're not in the military
this is not does not look well so one
are you doing any investigations to find
out who leaks that
and two what are you telling your troops
to make sure that they're not exposing
themselves and possibly putting
themselves
at risk by posting different things on
social media
so thank you for the question a there
there will be no investigation the
guardsmen have phones
it would be uh very difficult they
didn't compromise security
they're inside a buffered bubble
of layered security so
they'd have to get past the capitol
police the dc the all the national guard
so it's not a security risk that they
posted here's what i have done
and the chief of the national guard
bureau general hopkinson
and others three and four star generals
and command sergeant majors
have been out walking and talking to
guardsmen if you have a problem
let the chain of command know and we'll
fix it so that that's the guidance that
every single guardsman has been given
if you had a problem with the break area
let
someone in command know and we'll fix it
but there is no investigation security
was not compromised
it's good to see you again thank you for
your service
well thank you yours um and i do have
one more follow-up question
there's uh rumors that there is a armed
protest coming up by the end of this
month
are you posturing any of the guardsmen
to expect potential
um armed protests coming up before the
end of this
month how are you going to handle it
so so we have an adequate number of
guardsmen armed
we are relying on the intelligence from
the our federal partners and are
essentially our customers
in this case the united states capitol
police we're in support of them
and if there needs to be a shift in our
security posture
they will let us know and we will adjust
accordingly megan
last question um so because this
deployment has turned into
weeks and months and all these guardsmen
are on state orders to be here
they're not getting uh active duty days
toward
benefits retirement benefits that sort
of thing is there any reconsideration
of the the way that they've been
activated or some sort of memo maybe to
to rectify that um actually um
all this the soldiers that are here in
airmen are on federal orders
um under title 32 they remain under the
command and control their governor but
they're paid by the federal government
and they're under the control of uh
general
walker as the the d.c national guard
commanding general while they're here
okay i think we actually do have time
for one last question on the phone abc
yep are we here
okay all right anyone in the room have
one last question okay
good general walker any conversations
you're aware of or any process that
you're aware of to try to make sure that
the dc national guard
answers to the dc mayor to sort of
streamline the process of trying to
deploy them if the mayor wants to deploy
i'm not aware of any actual questions on
that i can i can share with you that the
district of columbia national guard was
established by president thomas
jefferson may of 1802
and the chain of command is exactly how
the secretary of the army described it
i since i've been in charge we've been
very responsive to the mayor she
provides
a request it comes to me i conduct
mission analysis i send it to the
secretary army
for his approval
okay we're out of time thank you very
[Music]
much
you